- yawn this is your third movie with
Gareth Evans the raid - how did it
compare to moranto and the raid one
Sofia Vergara particular - and bredda
surd against Ravana aggressive pitas
neodyne romantic technically ladira
simonia Brando great dancer on Brenda
Kataria panty all the three characters
in which movie are very different like
the agressivity and the technical
technical fighting skills of each movie
is different and it's a challenge
swallow challenging Mary and it's always
a new challenge for him and to explore
the new characters now can you tell us
what it's like what you enjoy most about
playing Mad Dog and can you show us some
of his signature moves Madoka - baccarat
padilla
lakukan Grandin Baba Amer be happy my
dog does um all the fighting scenes and
all his skills he doesn't really think
what's he's doing it's all really he he
would really do everything based on what
his boss would tell him so it's really a
fake party on your own yeah Nia yeah dee
da dee da dee da ba da da casa da da da
come on Nia yeah so it's really low he's
really loyal to his boss so he would
really do anything what his boss asked
him to without even thinking twice yeah
if you share with some moves
well it's the night set
you